c'était l'un des moments phare du salon
de l'immobilier d'entreprise le paris
saint germain a présenté ce mercredi et
11 décembre son futur centre
d'entraînement
le site sera implanté sur le nord de la
commune de poitiers à 25 minutes du parc
des princes d'abord c'est un projet qui
valorise le territoire avant de
valoriser la seule ville de poissy à
voir le paris saint germain sur 75
hectares avec 1000 emplois pendant la
durée des travaux 2 millions d'euros de
taxes annuelles pour la communauté
urbaine
oui c'est juste c'est juste exceptionnel
faut bien comprendre que une marque
comme le psg savoir quelle est la
implanté dans les yvelines aura un
retentissement international
c'est une publicité à zéro euro
donc c'est fait quelque chose de
formidable le site est encore un terrain
vague mais les fouilles archéologiques
ont débuté les premiers travaux seront
invisibles au printemps à terme le
centre comprendra les équipements
ultramodernes avec un dojo un terrain de
handball un stade de 5000 places et 17 1
de football dont un couvert
on n'a pas forcément cette ambition on
va tâcher d'être dans les meilleurs
c'est notre volonté d'être dans les
meilleurs donc on a un travail qu'on a
réalisé en toute humilité il ya encore
des très grands clubs qui sont présents
ont fait partie des très grands clubs on
va tâcher d'être le meilleur
la livraison définitive est à l'heure
actuelle programmée pour l'été 2022 le
coût total des travaux devrait avoisiner
les 220 millions d'euros